think about switching costs
if you are asking a customer to move
from a current supplier to working with
you
they're switching costs switching costs
are all that the time and money that's
going to be invested
into moving things over from one account
to another
to working with another company to yours
so you have to provide
incredible value because if you don't
it's not just that they may
like the company better if you're at the
same company level they're never going
to go with you because it costs
too much time and energy to switch you
have to
provide crazy amounts of value to get
them to come over to you
i got a youtube comment from alex who
wrote in he wants to basically create a
new facebook so once we hit the next
facebook and he says how his is
different
is he's going to help help share
in the revenue so instead of facebook
and get all the money he's going to give
the money to the people
80 percent of it he keeps 20. what a
great idea here's the problem
there's huge switching costs to moving
from facebook over to this network
because none of my friends are on your
new network why do i go to facebook it's
not because it's a great experience
because all of my friends are there so
why would i go
to your system i'm not going to go just
to make money
and i'm not going to make a lot of money
because i won't spend much time there
because my friends aren't there
so you need to come up with something
way better way more value crazy value
not just
making a little bit of money what's the
main reason for me to want to switch
from one network to another
listen today i was at a bank uh i got a
check that i had to deposit at bank of
montreal
okay and i didn't want to go to bank of
montreal all my banking is at td
okay but this check was an insurance
claim and i had to go to bank of
montreal so i had to go
to bank montreal to open up an account
to deposit the check just so i can then
close the account
i went in today opened up my account
everybody there was awesome
they were better than the people at my
td branch
it was great working with them we had
great conversations and they knew that i
was gonna leave
they knew that as soon as that money was
deposited and the check cleared i'm
closing my account
and i felt bad for a little bit you know
like i really like these guys like i
could i could
get along with them well i could see
myself doing banking there
i really liked them but there's too much
switching costs
as much value as they provided they
didn't give me enough to make it worth
my time to switch
all of my accounts i've got like 10
different bank accounts to move them
over to bank montreal even simple things
like
i use visa i love my visa credit card it
integrates well with my bank well they
use mastercard i don't have a mastercard
i don't want a mastercard
switching cost so even though they had
better service
i'm still not going to go there because
i'm used to using td and it's going to
cost me too much time
grief and aggravation to move over so if
you want people to switch from one thing
to another
the value has to be off the charts it's
got to be crazy good
if you want to compete with facebook you
got to provide something that facebook
doesn't even touch something that's way
better than facebook something that the
world hasn't even seen yet
and it's not going to be from giving
people 80 of the ad revenue it has to be
something
value based and whatever business in
you're in if you want people to switch
one customer
to you you've got to find a way to
really stand out
to really be different to really touch
people in the way that none of your
competition does
because the more they're built in and
locked in with their current suppliers
the harder it's going to be to get them
to do business with you
so always factor in those switching
costs to your business
otherwise you're not going to make any
sales
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give a thumbs up below
and i want to hear your thoughts what do
you think about switching costs what do
you think about alex's idea
let me know leave a comment underneath
if you have a question for your business
leave it below i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon